και θα έθελα να δω λείον παραπάνωο έαρνες εσωτερικά για τα διάφορα θέματα τα οποία
θα μας εύρουν α πάμε σε κακό σενάρι κλείνοντας τελευταία ρώτηση μιχάλημο μιχάλησεφανί της θα
έχει περισσότερε νών πλό κίν το επόμενο διάστημα στε μουγατικώ σεναγερμό ο νασι τουτι πσαρά
δεν των ενδιαφερικά ποια θέσει τα επόμενα χρόνια δε είναι στο μιάλλον του μηχάρη ότι
ο κτός απόάνθρωπος κιά θα νειτκ καυρέθι στην γιατική πυραμήδα το αρώς κιάθελιφώς συμτοριστή συμβουλίου
παρακολούθείς και είναι ρικο έργουποε είναι θέσι η οποία ενεσφως είμαγαμέ κρίνομε καθημερινά για τούτα
που λέω για το από κάμνο ρέτσενα διαφερει να βρεθι στην ίγεσα του κόμμα τούτε
μιλομόνο για πρόεδρωσης καιστις υπόλιπες θέσεις το δημοκρατικού συναγερμόό δεν δδε δεν είναι δεν είαι
έχω τέτοις επιδιώξεις κατανάγκη όδεν έχω τέτοιεσαι επιδιώξει το κατανάγκι φεύκοτο για για να μη
εκληφθεί λα αυτά μέρα δεν έχω τέτοιες επιδιώξεις ούτε επιδιώξεις κοινο στι κοινοβουλίν ούτε εκλογές
γουλευτικές πειδι συζήτήτο τον έναν διάστημα ότι μπορεί να σε στο ψυφοδελτι της λευκωσέχω ξεκαθαρίσει
από την αρχή ότι δεν μπορώ λόγολόγο άλλον υποχρεώσειωεπαγγελματικών δηλαδή λόγω της ργοτς δουλεις μου
εκείνο που έχει σημμαζία αυυελπιστώ να έχω όσυμπερισότεριείαι επίδραση γίνεται μέσω το ρόλου που ασκόσήμερα
στ το δημοκρομάλμο σε κατουους υντονιστήτο ηπολ οττίο εχάνειμε πταριστό πολύ αυτή τη συζήσει να
ας ακάα ευχαριστό πολύ κάθε γαλό τιλέφίλντααλάεό καευθασε στο τέλος του τα λέμε την ερχόμενη
ευδομα